la place des nations des joyaux du parc
jean drapeau est à l'abandon depuis 40
ans est dans un bien piètre it on parle
ici d'un impact sur le développement
économique de la métropole son
développement culturel
un nouvel espace dont les montréalais
vont pouvoir bénéficier on réhabilite
l'ensemble alimenter le site s'apprête à
retrouver son lustre d'antan
le projet de 75 millions de dollars dont
46 ont déjà été confirmés par la ville
de montréal ces deux responsabilités
tous les paliers de gouvernement parle
vraiment du rayonnement de la métropole
on parle vraiment de son rayonnement
culturel son aimant touristique on est
en contact avec les différents
ministères concernés et il ya de
l'appétit enthousiasme la place des
nations moderniser abritera un espace
public quatre saisons en restaurant un
lieu dédié à la diversité culturelle de
la métropole est un musée consacré à
expo 67
car à cette époque la place des nations
était un univers alger
de la place du peuple donc un lieu de
rassemblement qu'il accueillir 7000
personnes donc à celle ouvert magnifique
amphithéâtre et qui a été par la suite
d'utiliser pour terre des hommes donc
pendant
jusqu'au début des années 80 mais depuis
1981 la place est abandonnée est
interdite au public parce que trop
dangereuse c'était un vrai péché de le
laisser à l'abandon il ya quelque chose
d'exceptionnel qu'on peut offrir aux
touristes mieux nous connaître mieux
connaître notre histoire mais aussi aux
montréalais et se l'approprier en bonne
et due forme la place des nations
inciterait les montréalais et les
visiteurs à découvrir ses îles au trésor
et nous avons deux trésors inestimables
que d'autres villes ne peuvent pas en
avoir le grand parc du mont-royal et ce
parc est immense qui est exceptionnel le
fait d'avoir un nouveau lieu de
destination ce projet de réhabilitation
est le premier grand projet du plan
directeur de conservation d'aménagement
et de développement du parc jean drapeau
on ramène vraiment la place des nations
à telle qu'elle était à l'époque donc
avec un souci du détail patrimonial qui
va jusqu'au mobilier jusqu'au drapeau de
l'expo 67 qui seront présents
les appels d'offres pour les plans et
devis sont lancés l'ouverture au public
est prévue pour 2024 ici la vie
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]